Hey, fly safe.
I love you
sweetheart.
I love you.
Bye now.
My wife thinks
I'm a pilot.
But I'm not.
I have a secret family.
How do I sleep
at night?
I made both my wives
buy a Comforsleep.
( announcer )
Every day people across
America are finding out
that a Comforsleep
mattress
will give you the best
night's sleep of your life.
When I accidentally killed my
dog by leaving him in the car,
I thought I'd never sleep
another wink.
But then, a friend told me
about Comforsleep.
( announcer )
Don't you deserve the kind of
dark dreamless sleep
where not even God
can find you?
This mattress makes me sleep
like I wasn't molested.
Thanks, Comforsleep.
♪
( announcer )
With our patented
no-memory foam
you can forget
the past.
I have a stressful
job rejecting
totally reasonable
insurance claims.
So this is perfect
for me.
I didn't know
it was an orphanage
when I accelerated
through that front window.
Maybe now the
screaming will stop.
( announcer )
Comforsleep.
How do you sleep
at night?